hello everyone thank you so much for
joining my talk today my name is sarah
shapiro and i am a senior engineer at
mammoth biosciences and today i'm
excited to tell you some of the work
we've been doing on detecting sars cov2
with crispr
the mammoth's mission is to improve
lives by reading and writing the code of
life nemes was founded in 2018 with the
goal of advancing crispr
the crispr technology into products that
can reshape detection and treatment
and we use both a discovery pipeline for
new enzymes as well as some licenses
from uc berkeley in order to develop
the next generation crispr platform that
can enable life-saving diagnostics and
therapeutics
so all of this is based on leveraging
crispr's potential which at its heart is
a search engine
and so crispr has the ability to be
programmed by coupling a cath protein
with a guide rna that targets a protein
of interest
and by modifying the guide rna you can
target a
sequence of interest whether that be for
a virus such as sars cov2
or
for a genetic condition
and then furthermore these proteins
themselves
can be
programmed in order to perform a
targeted function and so depending on
the protein that could be
to read a nucleic acid sequence or to
write if you want to edit a certain
sequence
or even to knock out certain genes or to
modulate them
and so in order
to
leverage these proteins
for
developing new technologies mammoth has
developed a proprietary approach to
protein discovery
and so we look at various different
sources in order to discover new
proteins of interest
and these are fed to a bioinformatics
and machine learning platform which
identifies promising candidates and then
those candidates are put into high
throughput experimental screening in
order to further narrow down and
identify
candidates that are promising and can be
used in a wide variety of applications
all the way from diagnostics and
therapeutics to biomanufacturing and
agriculture
so specifically today i'm going to be
talking to you about the diagnostics
aspect
and
the proteins that mammoth uses are ideal
for diagnostics due to a few key
features
one of them is the programmable nature
of the platform where
by modifying the guide rna associated
with the cast protein you can target any
nucleic acid of interest
furthermore these proteins exhibit rapid
enzymatic recognition and so they very
quickly are able to find their target
and convert that into a signal which can
lead to rapid diagnostic assays
additionally due to the requirement for
the guide rna to hybridize to the target
there is a high molecular accuracy and
so all of this can lead to very simple
and specific assays that can be used for
diagnostics
and so for diagnostics in particular the
way that
many of these proteins work is that
once the protein is programmed by the
guide rna to target a specific sequence
once the
guide rna hybridizes to that sequence
and recognizes it then the complex is
activated and that activation then
unleashes
non-specific nucleus activity where the
enzyme begins to non-specifically cleave
other nucleic acids that happen to be
nearby
this can be leveraged in order
to
perform diagnostic applications because
you can use a reporter molecule that you
introduce into the solution
and that has a nucleic acid sequence
that you desire to be cleaved in order
to produce a signal
so for example you can have a
fluorophore molecule that's separated
from a clenching molecule by a nucleic
acid sequence and so when the sequence
is cleaved
in the presence of target that
fluorophore is released from its
quencher enabling the solution to become
fluorescent
so here is just a video so the cast
protein is complexed with its guide rna
and that complex is then able to
travel
through solution and the guide rna
programs the complex to to bind to its
target of interest
and after binding and recognition the
complex is then activated and it begins
to non-specifically cleave any other
nucleic acids that happen to be nearby
in this case this is again demonstrated
using a fluorophore quencher model where
you have a fluorophore separated by a
nucleic acid from a quencher and upon
cleavage that fluorophore is released
and becomes fluorescent allowing you to
measure the fluorescence of the solution
to determine
whether the target was present
and so this crispr detector platform can
be programmed to target any dna or rna
sequence of interest
that can be all the way from an
infectious pathogen to a cancer mutation
so
simply by changing the guide rna that is
associated with the protein
it gives a great flexibility as far as
diagnostic targets these targets could
be anything from viruses or bacteria
or even genotyping if you are interested
in identifying a gene mutation
or looking at host response
and so these
detector crispr caps platform has a few
key advantages on that are useful for
diagnostic assays looking for nucleic
acids
so one of these is that because the cast
protein is interrogating the
complementarity between the guide rna
and the target rna
there is increased specificity when you
compare to a traditional nucleic acid
amplification test
for example if you're looking at tacman
hybridization probes for comparison
furthermore these cast proteins have a
native signal amplification and the
protein performs multiple cleavage
events turning over
multiple reporter molecules per
identification of a single target and so
this can result in robust signal
generation from small amounts of
amplicon
additionally because of the specificity
of the cast protein it can sort through
messy isothermal amplification products
isothermal amplification tends to
be a bit messy and oftentimes it will
produce some non-specific products in
addition to the specific product you're
looking for
but when coupled with a cast enzyme the
cast enzyme can lead to a simplified and
faster workflow and fewer false
positives due to its specificity
and finally because the signal
generation is just dependent on nucleic
acid cleavage
the reporter
can be modified to
enable a variety of different readout
modalities and so you're not limited to
just fluorescence but you can have very
flexible formats for deploying your
diagnostic assay
and so as i mentioned
these detector
enzymes can lead to
increased signal to noise when you
compare to just doing an isothermal
amplification alone
and so on the left are some example
kinetic curves looking at
just isothermal amplification and you
can see that it's really hard to tell a
difference between the different wells
and all of the curves look fairly
similar but then when you couple this
with
a
crisper detection as shown on the right
the specificity of the crisper cast
complex leads
to
good differentiation in between your
positive and negative wells
and in this case the positive wells are
shown in orange and the negative in red
and you can see there's a very distinct
signal difference in between the two
furthermore the specificity of this
detector system
can
enable
even detection even down to single
nucleotide differences if you're looking
for example
single nucleotide polymorphism
and so the
image on the top illustrates this by
showing
a target that has been mutated in
various locations and the
the target that was designed but the
guide rna was designed for is shown by
the boxes
in pink
whereas
there was a comparison to different
point mutations mutating to the possible
different nucleotides at all the
different locations and we see that the
crispr cast complex has
really good specificity identifying its
target
and it's resistant to
a single nucleotide change all the way
from
the region right next to the pam down to
the very end of the spacer region
and so we can leverage this at mammoth
in order to
be able to genotype and identify
differences between a full wild-type
gene a heterozygous or a full mutant
and we can
compare the signal and very easily
stratify
into different buckets and allow us to
determine for the samples shown along
the bottom whether they were a wild type
heterozygous or a mutant
additionally because the detector
platform is compatible with different
readout modalities it can
enable application to
different types of diagnostic
technologies
and so i talked a bit about fluorescence
previously as a readout but the assay
can also be coupled to a lateral flow
readout
where you have in
response to the cleavage event of the
crispr cast complex
you generate a different signal on a
lateral flow strip and so you can
observe this change by eye similar to
the way you would for example in a home
pregnancy test
additionally the crispr pass
complex can be coupled with a secondary
enzyme that will generate a colorimetric
change and so in this case you can have
a change in color in response to the
presence of target and that change in
color can be identified by eye
and a final option is to do
electrochemical based detection using
instead a reporter that is
electrochemically active and exhibits a
different electrochemical signal after
cleavage
all of these different advantages of
crispr enables it to have broad
application across the full continuum of
testing all the way from laboratory test
to at-home tests
and the programmable nature of the
detector platform means they can use it
to detect any different indications
while its high specificity and
sensitivity
provides great usefulness in very
different
diagnostic settings
and so this can be useful both on a
laboratory basis where
the goal is to increase throughput
and
using for example automated tests in
order to run as many tests as possible
all the way from that to
on at home tests where
you're interested in having a single use
disposable device where someone could
test
at their own home
and in order to do this you need
something that is low cost
and very rapid so
the person doesn't have to wait a long
time when running the test as well as be
able to be distributed into homes
and so
the
current coven 19 pandemic has really
validated the need for rapid and
accurate diagnostic tests that can be
quickly deployed and mammoth worked very
rapidly in response to
the beginning of the pandemic
mammoth first developed an assay very
rapidly in response to the publication
of the full viral sequence in january of
2020
and we worked with clinical
collaborators at ucsf in order to
develop first a peer-reviewed manuscript
that was published in nature
biotechnology in april of 2020.
we further were able to obtain
partnerships
with
gfk and with darpa to develop
decentralized testing options as well as
some funding from the nih in
partnerships with milicar sigma hamilton
and agilent
in order to develop a lab-based test
called detector boost
and
all of the efforts surrounding the assay
has enabled us to go from paper to
accelerated product development in under
six months
i'm going to talk to you a little bit
about both the lab-based tests as well
as decentralized testing
but first i would like to give an
overview of the essay itself which was
published in a manuscript in
biotechnology
in
april of 2020
and this was the world's first
peer-reviewed manuscript demonstrating
the use of crispr diagnostics for covet
19.
and so in response to
the
pandemic mammoth scientists worked very
quickly in order to develop an assay
that could leverage crispr and use it to
detect stars cov2
and so we developed two different
essays for two different
pieces of the viral genome one is the
e gene region
where the the guide rna that we
developed overlaps with the w-h-o-e
amplicon
and also an assay for the n-gene region
where the guide rna overlaps with the
cdc and two amplicon
and so the first step in developing the
essay was to make sure
that the guide rnas were specific for
the target of interest and didn't have
cross reactivity and so the graph in the
bottom left
shows a comparison
of
the guides for the engine and aegean
target
as well as rna-sp which we use as a
sample input control
and we see that the n-gene and the
e-gene guides are both very specific for
that particular target and don't show
cross-reactivity with some other common
coronaviruses
whereas the rnap or the sample input
control is present across the different
coronavirus samples
furthermore mammoth leveraged a lateral
flow based readout in this test in order
to eliminate the need for bulky
fluorescence equipment
and this lateral flow test
will
determine based on a visual readout
the result of the assay
and so as the cast complex is activated
it cleaves the reporter that when
the
product of the reaction is put on a
lateral flow strip if the reporter has
been cleaved then it generates a
different signal compared to if the
target was not present and the reporter
was not cleaved
and so the crisper portion of the assay
works incredibly rapidly and so the
graph near the bottom right shows the
signal
after different reaction times of the
crispr part of the reaction and we see
that
almost instantaneously you can see a
difference in between the positive and
negative samples
the lateral flow readout is shown in the
bottom right and we see that we can
start to distinguish about two and a
half minutes but after five minutes you
really see
a strong difference in between your
positive and negative
mammoth further validated the test by
collaborating with ucsf and testing on
real clinical samples
and so this slide shows a comparison
from tests with 83 different clinical
samples
and so if the
both the engine and e-gene assays were
positive for stars cov2 then the sample
was called positive
if either one of the n or ng and or a
gene were
positive then the sample was presumptive
positive whereas if both the ng and a
gene were negative and the rna p control
as a sample input control was positive
then
the sample was called stars kobe 2
negative
and using that scheme we were able to
obtain
a positive percent agreement
of 95 and a negative percent agreement
of 100
illustrating the
applicability of crispr to
real clinical samples in response to the
emerging pandemic
and so mammoths further leveraged the
assay in order to
develop a lab-based
test that could
impact
high-throughput testing that's done in
diagnostic laboratories so that is the
detector boost starts 2 reagent kit
this is in partnership with agilent and
their bravo instrument as well as
hamilton and their star instrument
and
it has the potential of increasing
testing capacity up to thousands of
tests per day due to
the simple and rapid crispr test
and as a result of this can get results
faster up to two times faster than pcr
workflows
furthermore because the assay is very
simple there is less hands-on time it's
less than an hour which
reduces the fte load and can allow
employees to
focus on other tests while increasing
diagnostic throughput
and finally it has a performance similar
to rt-pcr with an lod of 150 copies per
milliliter
so in comparison to rtpcr the detector
boost assay takes approximately 90
minutes per 96 well plate in order to
run whereas rtpcr takes about 140
minutes per 96 well plate and also
involves some manual steps
for the detector boost assay
we have a duplexed assay with thyroscope
v2 engine as well as rnasp is an
internal control
and it displays an analytical log at 150
copies per milliliter
furthermore in a clinical study with 230
nasopharyngeal swabs
we were able to obtain 100
positive percent agreement
with in samples that had a comparator ct
that was less than our estimated lg
so in addition to applying the crispr
detector platform to laboratory-based
testing mammoth has also worked to
develop a decentralized testing platform
and so for the sam the decentralized
prototype it's able to
perform the full assay in less than 40
minutes including extraction
amplification and the detector crispr
reaction
and so to develop this prototype we
integrated the assay chemistry onto
a prototype device that only requires a
single user step
and allows for sample to answer in just
40 minutes
mammoth tested this on 100 different
prototypes and found that we were able
to obtain 96
overall agreement for detection of stars
cov2
we've manufactured more than 500 of
these prototypes
furthermore these prototypes also
convert the signal from the assay into a
positive negative indicator light in
order for the results to be unambiguous
to the user
and so at the end of the assay there is
a measurement cycle that is initiated
and then the data is collected
and an algorithm calls the result and
then based on that result
the appropriate light is
is lit up whether that's a positive or a
negative call
and as i mentioned we tested this on a
hundred different prototype devices and
found that we were able to obtain a
positive agreement of 100
and a negative agreement of 92 with
overall agreement of 96
and so all of this illustrates the
applicability of crispr and
the advantages of
having the highly specific and rapid
testing that can really impact the
future of diagnostics and can enable
molecular testing that is in the palm of
your hand
and with that i'd like to thank the
entire mammoth bio sciences team mammoth
has a lot of great people who work here
and it's a pleasure to come to work with
them every day
as well as i'd like to
give a shout out to all of our
collaborators including ucsf for the
nature biotech paper and the clinical
studies as well as the many other
collaborators on the various projects we
do at mammoth thank you so much for
listening to my talk